vous m'avez pris en photo
pourquoi
je suis photographe
dans les tranchées les champs de
bataille les zones de combat
de guerre avant tout je couvre aussi des
événements sportifs je m'appelle
Augustine Beck
qu'est-ce que vous allez en faire de
cette photo
si elle est réussie je crois que
j'essaierai de la vendre un magazine
maintenant que vous en parlez Beach
Campbell mangeant une gaufre
bonjour bonjour
on s'est déjà vu je suis la maman de
cette cookie girls scout dont vous êtes
l'idole je sais vous ne m'auriez
peut-être pas reconnu sur mon uniforme
vous étiez excellente dans le rôle de la
traînée dans le bordel qui a une amnésie
et qui devient pédiatre vous étiez
vraiment tous les personnages que j'ai
joué c'est celui que je préfère pourquoi
personne d'autre là aimer oui moi non
plus merci certains l'ont aimé oh j'en
suis sûr moi oui
combien de temps ils peuvent nous garder
à astéroïde City je veux dire légalement
moi je suis pas avocat mais je dirais
tant qu'il leur plaira il faudrait
déposer une injonction et plaider
l'affaire avec succès 6 mois un an bien
sûr il faudrait aussi qu'on engage une
action civile pour perdre de retraite
qu'on devrait s'en aller sans attendre
je suis pas sûr qu'il puisse nous en
empêcher sans tuer qui que ce soit
l'idée est intéressante est-ce qu'on
peut aller loin avec le réacteur dorsal
demandez à Roger ou à son fils
apparemment il est poursuivi pour avoir
révélé des secrets d'État ça n'aboutira
jamais moi je suis pas pressé j'aime
bien le désert j'aime bien les aliens
d'où vous sortez ça les prototypes sont
gardés en lieu sûr aucun jeune astronome
n'est autorisé et y accéder sans
l'autorisation de la mort c'est
peut-être vrai mais mes autres
c'est une quarantaine difficile
pressez vos armes le général Gibson dit
DPC vos armes vous êtes marié